ok
oh mio dio siamo sugli specchi di oggi
lo do fare la trasformazione il trucco
and his own make up transformation
avviso in anticipo che io non sono una
stroke attrice non sono bravo a
truccarmi e poco mi truccavo molto di
più ma non riconosciuto si ricorre di
vetro cavo tantissimo per un periodo mi
toccavo tantissimo poi un po di meno poi
comunque tutti i giorni e poi ho smesso
si che questo completamente ora mi
trucco molto poco sopracciglia matita e
volta quindi ho perso un po per la
passione per il trucco
però penso che sia comunque super
divertente e non vedo l'ora dipendente
come riesco a trasformarmi quindi
sommando notte abilitate
però vediamo se riusciamo a fare questa
make up transformation allora seguirò il
tutorial tik tok 21 11 il nome del
canale è una ragazza grafica sicuramente
avrete visto perché si trasforma in
celebrità uomini donne e bravissima
bravissimo a truccarsi e ha fatto questo
tutorial su come fare queste
trasformazioni e in più abbiamo anche
vari accessori strani tipo le lenti a
contatto la parentesi non ho mai messo
raccontato 0 poi abbiamo della sera poi
vedrete perché
e poi delle cose molto particolari per
gli occhi allora siete pronti prendete
patatine pop corn e lasciato un bel
match tra questo video e iniziamo subito
per evitare qua per aiutarmi e
sostenermi così non ci annoiamo nel
mercato parlare con qualcuno
oltre a voi comunque il primo passaggio
se chiedo che chicca la prima che con lo
scotch sei un pittore di trucco in
pratica il primo passaggio
scusate le campane per fondere timore
tre video il primo passaggio di mettere
lo scotch squadre che in pratica se
avete visto il video di queste
trasformazioni mettono lo scorso 4
somigliare diviso perché molte avviati
che hanno il viso un po conto che non
c'è niente rimane col viso tondo ma gli
piace per il viso un po più sottile io
ho già il viso abbastanza sottile vedete
quindi non so quanta differenza fare non
so neanche se riuscirò a farlo le
compagne sembra che stiano aumentando di
volume a poco per dare single figlia
altro fu lungo ma mister d'acqua diventa
riproviamo ecco
ce l'ha fatta il motore a questa cosa
delle loro che schiacciano questa parte
qua forse perché può lanciare un peso
troppo sottili ora questo l'altro
[Musica]
terribile ma per cui si vede dovrebbe
vedersi ma allora a me sembra un po più
sottile scrivetemi voi nei commenti
e terribile perché non riesce a parlare
bene aprire bene una bocca zucchero
fastidioso comunque il prossimo
passaggio del prossimo passaggio metodo
il fondotinta super bianco perché mi
vedo come ho spiegato nell'altro video
in asia e secchia vale di carnagione per
una carnagione molto chiara è sinonimo
di bellezza come per noi avere una
carnagione abbronzata per la maggior
parte di noi diciamo è sinonimo di
bellezza tutti i tipi di pelle tutte le
carnagioni sono bellissime canone di
bell ex esatto io ho già pelle chiara ma
a me non piace più per essere affrontata
questa chiara non so neanche se tanto
chiaro non ho mai trovato
vediamo un po come anni che non uso il
fondotinta è stranissimo abbiamo un po
secondo come mi sta schiarendo non è
molto chiaro però ho anche una terra
debutta fece anche del corretto retto è
chiaro lo stesso quindi forse questo può
aiutare
abbiamo un po ci sono più chiara
insomma ok ma vogliono più chiari e ora
ricomincio a truccarmi promettere della
polvere per fissare in trucco forse miss
chiarisce anche un pochino perché bianca
oddio come si apre questo è super ok
ragazzi questo passaggio super
complicato e sicuramente fallirò anche
perché non ho mai usato questa cosa
questa è c'era modellante e in pratica
bisogna ammodernarlo poi cercando di
seguire tutto quello che fa lei mentre
la sul naso perché se avete visto questi
settori al metodo questo tipo dice ero
assordato e fanno un'altra forma di nato
io la sto modellando un po quindi adesso
propri dati quasi slime però è veramente
complicato e della prima volta che l'ho
avuto allora lei dice di mettere un
pezzo così mi metterò un mostro adesso
ora sappiamo dell'arma anche allora dice
di schiacciare e spalmarla un po poi
siccome questo non è il colore della mia
pelle dopo dovrà ripassare il fondotinta
sopra e devo semplicemente schiacciarla
un po sperare che sembra una cosa te c'è
mi sembra chiaro con l'altro ancora un
po però si sta funzionando aiuto ho
sbagliato forma completamente nel fatto
il naso giganteschi l'assenza si vota ok
ragazzi dopo tipo 40 minuti questo è il
risultato più decente è in realtà il mio
naso a una forma super fashion adesso il
padrone fanno per assottigliarlo
suppongo e io ho questa forma un po
strana adesso proprio bene ora vado a
coprirlo con un po di fondotinta
propriamente il colore è diverso in
pratica ho sbagliato perché per
applicarlo dovevo bagnarmi le mani
altrimenti si attaccava tutto alle mani
e quindi a me ovviamente sia attaccato
tutto alle mani oddio sembra ancora
bellini per ora mi su trasformando male
o che allora
ora è giunto il momento di utilizzare
questi g per chi non lo sapesse queste
sono molto popolari in asia
in pratica questa fanno e uno sticker
che stima che questo lo sa quanto è
brava ingrandisce gli occhi come dicevo
nell'altro video molte ragazze asiatiche
vogliono gli occhi un po più grandi
perché lo chiesi a fico e a mandorla un
punto pochino più freddo è bellissimo lo
chiesi a fico vedo perché si ha bisogno
di ingrandirlo però insomma questo è
sinonimo di bellezza e nate agli occhi
molto gravi
quindi utilizzano questa sottospecie che
può fare ingrandire gli occhi io voglio
che già abbastanza grave quindi sono
molto curioso di vedere come diventano
una volta che applico poi allora non li
ho mai provata allora sia anche un
progetto per applicare distrazioni non
si capisce niente penso che sia amore
anno non decide nè sembra coreano ok è
cupa e ora ho messo via un po una
qualche differenza
cosa vogliono se non tanto a questo
metterà un po più sopra basso che se ne
possono mettere anche due quindi
permettermi un altro così potenzia
l'effetto è stranissimo che la casa
tutti cosa qua che ti tirano palpebra
veramente non so come facciano quelle
che fanno che tutte le tornate a fare
tutto il giorno con queste cose addosso
il coach questa cosa qua e al ferro
abbiamo un pregio alle reti a contatto
come aiuto palpebra
[Musica]
voglio fare differenza da questo e
quest'occhio no che differenza si vede
oddio che dico
[Musica]
che ragazzino tale differenza a me
sembra di avere gli occhi un pochino che
opero tantissimo sembra che ci sia meno
spazio nella mia palpebra e di sembra
che o meno palpebra però sono un posto
conti allora il prossimo passaggio sono
le lenti a contatto è un mostro paura di
questo passaggio
queste sono le leggi che ordinato e sono
molto diverse realtà dalla foto perché
nella foto sua moto non erano proprio
quelle lenti grandi circles
mi sembra che si chiamano che usano
proprio gli alleati schiera in olio chi
molto molto grandi ma funzionalmente non
mi sembrano queste comunque preso il
colore blu perché sono curioso di vedere
come sarebbe il mio chi blu per
solamente tender evitare per decreto
non ha senso questa borsa galleggiante
ok allora ho visto dei tutorial
grazie
ecco paravento
e difficile non solo tre gli occhi è
molto più difficile di quanto pensassi
torniamo quest'altro occhio mi viene
male mentre si però adesso deve muovere
perfetto giappone perfetto lasciato
entrata nuova beta difficilissimo come
fa gente normale mette minuti già
entrata sì lo dovresti spingere più
verso è del tutto entrata si ok no ok
oh mio dio no oh mio dio fa paura verso
cosa cyborg fatto come ci vedi tirato
bene bene bene di brevi si dosa bene
tranne al lato c'è qualcosa di un pò
appannato forse lo sporcato un po e
quindi leggermente appannato però mi
sembra di vedere un'altra persona è
troppo strano attenti contrarsi e
arrivato il momento dell'altra lente
aiuto già stato difficile con una ok
allora sono riuscito a farlo guardando
dall'altra parte primo no sì no no
cazzi ce l'ho fatta finalmente mi sembra
di essere un altro per troppa
impressione determi con questi occhi
attenti possono meglio che un po più
grandi vedete che meglio purtroppo un
pochino più grandi e mi trovo strano dio
vi piacerebbe se vi trasformarsi sempre
così così normalmente comunque allora
per completare il look una cosa che
utilizzano per fare prendere il look
ancora più estremo è un albo che si
chiama si chiama beauty cam e vi faccio
vedere come loro riescono ad avere
l'effetto estremo di peso completamente
diverso allora guardate un po appunto
riescono a assottigliare ancora di più
diviso possono fare dei richter
vedete che già sono comunque
diversissima mi ha schiarito la pelle
poi tifano per le super sbiadita le
guance vedete che ora fa proprio alte di
precisione e questo è quello che
assottiglia ancora tutto il viso voce le
mascelle vedete qua saluto più lunghe e
strette sembra gli occhi questi sono
ancora più grandi guardate a paziente
ore poi il mio tipo le date sembra un
alieno questo giorno
ali fabio ravvicinati guardate un po
questa è la trasformazione cioè come
dovrei sembrare è la trasformazione che
utilizzano loro oltre i trucchi abbiamo
messo molto più brave a tenere il trucco
è tutto però utilizzando anche in questa
sono completamente diverse e ora abbiamo
togliere tutto così vediamo la
trasformazione assieme che iniziano dal
caso bellissimo sogno lo stato almeno so
che respira nuovamente ottico capano
toglie
sono fatta
vediamo la differenza perché tutto
questo
[Musica]
il mio colore degli occhi e si vede che
definitivamente non ho gli occhi blu
anche se molti di voi dicono che gli
occhi blu ma guardate che differenti
[Musica]
l'ho fatto non ci posso credere allora
pure il preferite con i miei occhi così
o con gli occhi blu mi preferite con
tutto quel trucco senza trucco un po di
trucco poco trucco niente trucco
ditemi voi nel commento devi sapere se
questo video vi è divertito io mi sono
divertita un sacco ma non pensavo ci
volesse così tanto tempo stiamo il modo
da tipo tre ore quindi mi raccomando
lasciato un bel like di supporto fatemi
sapere se volete vedere altri video un
po diversi come questo scrivetemi pure i
vostri le vostre idee e commenti
e io vedo un bastone enorme ma e mi
lasciò a quattro case linee su cui
potete cliccare per vedere i prossimi
invidio le mie altre challenge i miei
video divertenti clicca su quello che
preferite e buona visione
ciao ciao